les américains les bostoniens en
particulier surtout souligner
aujourd'hui pénible très peinée
d'anniversaire il ya tout juste un an le
marathon de boston a été visé par un
attentat ou trois personnes ont été
tuées et 260 autres blessés je sais bien
une cérémonie grandiose peut être mais
le message reste très simple très sobre
post on n'oublie pas
post on n'oubliera jamais ce 15 avril
2013 ces deux bombes artisanales posées
à la ligne d'arrivée les deux explosions
les trois morts les 260 blessés des
victimes comme patrick downs il était
dans la foule ce jour là avec sa femme
l'explosion leur arracher une jambe
chacun ne pas vivre en victime penser à
l'avenir voilà ce qu'il est venu dire en
ce premier anniversaire
dès le jour de l'attentât post ont
refusé cette étiquette de victimes
la terreur ne peut pas gagner boston
strong la ville forte c'est sa devise
depuis nous avons vécu une nuit très
sombre dit le maire mais nous sommes une
ville de champion deux frères partis en
guerre sainte contre les états unis
voilà l'histoire l'aîné et tués le
lendemain le jeune joe hart ianaïev
attend son procès en isolement total 30
accusations pèsent contre lui
il est passible de la peine de mort
cette jeune danseuse et une des seize
victimes amputé elle évoque la
communauté des amputés de beauce ton uni
dans l'adversité dit elle tant elle fait
partie maintenant bien malgré elle et
jian et d'autres comme elle incarne bien
la devise basten strong elle dansait
avant les attentats elle continue de
danser sur une prothèse
des symboles des images qui inspire les
médias américains comme ce spectateur au
chapeau chaos boy qui a sauvé la vie
d'un des marathoniens 14h49
lors de la première explosion sous un
ciel gris c'est la minute de silence en
hommage au coureur aux secouristes
un hommage à toute une ville qui refuse
de céder à la peur ici joyce n'est que
radio-canada washington
alors si vous le permettez on va revenir
sur ces événements tragiques en
compagnie de deux femmes qui étaient il
ya un an
aux premières loges du marathon de
boston tout d'abord j'accueille marilyn
nos chirurgiens orthopédistes vous
faisait partie de l'équipe de médicale à
l'arrivée merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et chantal gariépy
il faut suspendre susanne bier rieppi
c'est un nom dont je devais pc qui vous
la connaissez très bien les métérologues
à radio-canada qui elle était au
marathon de boston pause avait couru le
marathon cette journée là je commencerai
avec vous docteur no vous étiez à la
ligne d'arrivée je vouvoyais écoutez le
reportage d'origine et pure ce sont des
émotions ce sont des souvenirs qui sont
encore très vif et difficile à lalimite
à soutenir encore aujourd'hui oui tout à
fait des images qu'on a vu en boucle
l'année passée c'est moi j'étais
exactement dans l'action dans ces images
donnant plusieurs d'entre elles on voit
en fait en réalité les photos donc c'est
très difficile à voir sur un an plus
tard quel était votre rôle exactement
moi j'étais je faisais partie de
l'équipe médicale à l'imagerie donc on
était un groupe de quatorze op disque
puis notre rôle était pas très compliqué
en fait c'était juste de recueillir les
coureurs qui étaient un peu déshydratée
ou qu'is avaient eu un malaise à
l'arrivée donc notre rôle était loin
d'eux
de participer un champ de guerre le sont
parce que c'est ça s'est transformé
rapidement la médecine de brousse vous
avez fait face à quoi exactement
c'était quoi
une mare de sang mais oui en fait tout
se passait dans une mare de sang sur la
rue une trentaine de blessés puis
c'était tout des blessures des membres
inférieurs des amputations puisse les
imputer les gens quittent à amputer
leurs membres étaient à côté d'eux des
eaux sûreté un peu partout cette idée
blessure qu'on est habitué de voir un
hôpital dans une salle d'urgence mais
d'en voir plusieurs en même temps sur la
rue avec l'espèce d'odeurs de bong qui
avait s'était donné jamais formés pour
ce genre de situation je pense pas qu'on
ait jamais fourmis honnêtement si ça
murray est arrivé et je passe à vivre
aux pommes et sissach y arrivait je
pense que je serai plus prête à faire
face à la situation juste de l'avoir
vécu une première fois je réponds
l'espèce de surprise de la chose
est ce que vous considérez et là je fais
appel à votre humilité mais est ce que
vous considérez que vous avez réussi à
sauver la vie de certaines personnes
personnellement je dirais que non je
pense en tant que groupe d'efforts
communs oui on a sauvé la vie de
plusieurs individus aussi de la première
bombe eut aucun décès est donc en groupe
on a réussi à tout évacuer les gens ce
qu'ils avaient des blessures vraiment
qu'ils pouvaient atteindre leur ville
ont été traitées très rapidement
puis non je pense pas que
personnellement j'ai sauvé personne mais
je pense qu'on en gros pendant le
sourire oui vous suzanne vous avez
franchi la ligne d'arrivée et là je
pense que c'est à ce moment là que
l'attentât a eu lieu quelques quelques
secondes après plus de six mois j'étais
chanceuse de 20 minutes parce que bon
j'avais passé j'en ai fait des marathons
envoient leurs un long moment de
l'explosion 24 heures neuf
j'en ai fait des marathons en quatre
heures 9 et cette fois ci j'étais un peu
plus rapide
dieu merci et puis c'est ça donc 20
minutes de chance dans mon cas par
contre si on arrive à l'hôtel moelle et
mes enfants ont dit maman viens voir
bien voir et oui voir on a déjà entendu
des histoires n'ont en effet pas rendu à
trois morts on avait un le petit garçon
qui était décédé on avait à peu près dix
blessés donc une fois l'hôtel mais enfin
ma peine vient voir maman et le c'est là
qu'il me dise on était assis là où il y
avait la première explosion
alan doss a pris tout un autre sens là
évidemment ma chance c'est vraiment des
minutes 20 minutes et est ce que vous
avez l'intention de retourner à boston
parce que bon leur merad le marathon se
rejoue le dit prochain excuse à
l'intention de recourir au début je me
suis dit non je retournerais pas mais
j'avais un temps de qualification alors
c'est toujours un petit peu tentant
aussi d'en profiter et puis avec le
temps bon bah je m'inscris
et oui je suis là en fin de semaine
prochaine vous savez les marathoniens on
a une détermination c'est un gros
travail c'est long avant d'y arriver de
s'inscrire d'être qualifié il y en a qui
font ça pendant des années des nombreux
marathons avant de pouvoir être accepté
là on réussit on y va on sait ce qui
nous fait peur ou non vous est pris en
10 le mot non non non j'ai pas peur je
sais que ça va être un endroit très
sécuritaire probablement le plus
sécuritaire sur la planète à ce moment
là la sécurité a été renforcée
il ya des caméras partout l'ambiance va
être extraordinaire j'en suis certaine
et non je ne pense pas et vous docteur
no vous y retournez également le tout à
fait j'y vais aussi fonction pendant que
madame marathonienne nuit dans l'équipe
médicale mais je sais cela pour vendre
mon équipe médicale allait passer voir
mes amis c'était important pour vous
d'être présente plus tard oui
extrêmement important d'aller sur le
site c'est
un peu comme pour terminer une forme de
thérapie le post post resler qui a été
assez intense années passées il faut que
soit l'heure pour vraiment le vivre
encore une fois à voir que ça va bien se
finir terminé marathon de boston de la
turquie pour vous dire exactement
on va profiter de notre présence usain
il va faire beau lundi censée faire beau
et vrai merci beaucoup à vous deux
journées